[Music]
i'm asking them to come on our side
and use that feverish uh energy that
they have
to put boots on the ground and make real
change and get jake
little jake who was shot seven times in
the back justice
we're putting half a billion pounds more
into these
innovative new next generation tests and
then
rolling them out in a way that helps
control the virus
i told my wife i promised to her that
i'll come back
god gave me again a chance to wear again
the uniform
metallica loves being out of its comfort
zone and
and stepping into uh to know and
unexpected challenges so
when this opportunity presented itself
again last year we were ready to jump
back in
the protest started after police shot 29
year old black man jacob blake several
times in the back
during a domestic disturbance on august
the 23rd
well then three days later president
trump sent in the national guard and
yesterday he defended that decision by
tweeting
if i didn't insist on having the
national guard activate and go into
kenosha wisconsin
there would be no kenosha right now i
will see you
on tuesday well it's democratic
challenger
joe biden has condemned the shooting and
the violence that followed it
he tweeted burning down communities is
not protest
it's needless violence violence that
endangers
lives violence that guts businesses that
is
wrong this is 28th street in kenosha
this actually dermot is the street where
jacob blake was shot a week ago past
sunday
donald trump will not be coming here he
is due to
arrive at a school a few blocks away but
as you can see behind me it's a
bit of a party see this is a rival event
organized
by the community here to to showcase the
positive side
of kenosha they don't want donald trump
here he would not be welcome here
uh there has been no attempt to contact
the family
of jacob lake according to family
members uh even though
donald trump said that he tried to
negotiate a path to the family via
uh their pastor i'm joined by justin
blake he's the uncle
of jacob lake many thanks for your time
mr blake how are you doing thank you sir
um very well
uh tell me this donald trump is in town
correct
he says that he comes with a positive
message because
had he not done what he did there would
be no kenosha because of
the violence what do you say to that
that's a misnomer
the fact of the matter is we talked to
the african descendants
in kenosha we sat down with the
organizations here
we led a protest last saturday at almost
8 000 people
and we changed their minds and their
spirit and their soul
what they're doing anybody could
understand we've been walked over dogged
out for 300 years
we built this country so i can
understand why they would want to burn
something but i'm asking them to come on
our side
and use that feverish energy that they
have
to put boots on the ground and make real
change and get jake
little jake was shot seven times in the
back justice
tell me this how is jacob blake you're
your nephew
nephew's doing great he's hanging in
there he's paralyzed
how would anybody wake up and do this
paralyzed but i'm here to tell you
he's resilient he's a blank warrior his
great
his grandfather my father is looking
down shining on him right now
he marched three times with king we've
been fighting the same battle
over and over since my father actually
times with king we're going to get it
straight in 2020.
starting right here in kenosha tell me
this why do you think
donald trump has come here and what
would you say to him
it's a free country obviously you can go
anywhere who wouldn't want to be around
connecting these great people
but the fact of the matter is don't take
focus away from the real story
the real story is i only want to say a
road cop
a cop went out of his position and shot
our nephew seven times
and we want justice he's not here to
record to
console the families he's here to
uh get comfortable to the militia
make a young killer hero 70 year old
child
he should be part of the country
he's operating at a very low moral level
[Music]
working well that is the health
secretary's assessment of the
government's coronavirus testing regime
despite some people being directed to
travel to test centers
a hundred miles away i began by asking
mr hancock about the
500 million investment being announced
today to ramp up
testing capacity being able to expand
mass testing with these new technologies
it
is a huge positive step forward
in our battle against the virus if you
think about it
a combination of everybody doing social
distancing
and then testing to find out where the
virus is
is our best way of avoiding having to do
local lockdowns and our best way of
keeping the virus under control
so you know at the moment if you take a
test the swab goes in your throat it has
to go off to the lab
we get most of them back the next day
but
changing that to something where you can
just have some saliva
and 20 minutes later you've got the
result that means we can have
many many more people tested and also
you can just get the result fast and
know that you are covered safe
and how do we access those tests well
we're dealing with about 100 different
testing companies at the moment who are
have got new innovative technologies and
when those tests
work we're always putting them through
rigorous trials because obviously
the tests have to work and we're then
rolling them out and that's one of the
things that we're announcing today
putting half a billion pounds more into
these innovative new next generation
tests
and then rolling them out in a way that
helps control
the virus so for instance in salford in
greater manchester
and we we're taking the testing right
into the center of town
so that everybody can get a test and we
can find out
anybody who is asymptomatic doesn't have
symptoms
but has coronavirus and likewise you can
then start to think about how you can
use this
for much more ways of opening things up
and
getting life back to normal because
people will be able to know
quickly whether or not they've got
coronavirus and therefore have the
confidence
knowing that they don't have it if they
get a negative test
to um to to go about more normal life
something that you will know about and
i'm sure you will want to comment on is
tony
abbott i can see that you're wearing
your nhs pride badge
uh i wear mine with pride is what you've
tweeted previously tony abbott who was
the former
prime minister of australia some
suggesting that he may well be
potentially a us a uk trade ambassador
he says he feels threatened by
homosexuality he also says elderly
people should have been left to die
naturally from covet
and men are better set to exercise
authority than women
is it the right sort of person to
represent us
well as far as i understand it the
proposal is that
um uh mr abbott supports the uk on trade
policy
which is an area in which he's got a
huge amount of expertise
you know i i bow to nobody in my support
for everybody to
uh to to love who they love uh whoever
that
is and and um and and
well as as you know and as we've talked
about uh a lot but i think you know
we want we need to have the best experts
in the world in there working
in their field and as the former prime
minister of australia
obviously mr abbott's got a huge amount
of experience
even if he's a homophobic misogynist
well i i'm i think that that is uh i
don't think that's
uh true uh i don't i haven't seen him
just told you what he said
i'm sure you don't support some of his
comments he's a homophobe
and he's a misogynist well
uh he's also an expert in uh trade
so one plays off against the other
really is that really what you're saying
health secretary come on
well no what i'm saying is that we need
experts in
different areas and um somebody who's
the former prime minister of australia
is obviously an enormous expert in the
uh
in the field of trade it doesn't change
my views
this is where it all began and you would
hardly know
life in wuhan is back to normal its
people apparently carefree
[Music]
the city is unrecognizable from january
when it was in the grip of a mystery
disease
one that didn't yet have a name sky news
was among the thousands caught in the
chaos and confusion of the first ever
lockdown
which prompted a mass evacuation seven
months later though there are still
questions how did wuhan become ground
zero for the coronavirus
what did the communist party know and
when in china
those questions are asked only by the
very brave
[Music]
there was no ambulance to take him to
hospital so his family set out to walk
this six miles in the freezing cold
before they were picked up in a locals
tuk-tuk it was too late
he died of respiratory failure as he sat
in the emergency waiting room
thousands here are grieving but few
would dare what jalalei
did next she's suing the local
government
for compensation and for a public
apology
fighting for what she believes is fair
against a system that does not tolerate
dissent
just
foreign
foreign
foreign
it's been almost two weeks since alexei
navalny fell into a coma on an early
morning flight from siberia
these his terrible cries of pain before
he lost consciousness
which russian medical staff attributed
to low blood sugar levels
now this stark announcement from the
german chancellor
alexey navalny alexanovani was the
victim of an attack with a chemical
nerve agent of the novichok group
this poison could be identified
unequivocally in tests
so it's clear that alexi navalny is the
victim of a crime
dammit he was supposed to be silenced
and i
together with the entire german
government to condemn this in the
strongest possible terms
if uh russian authorities theoretically
theoretically would be so greeky
barbaric
that they decided to poison uh alicia
navarney
was the reason to send him to the
germany
no reason not barbaric
we are putin and his team not poisoning
his political ambulance novi talk is
part of
what um are known as organophosphate
nerve agents
it is the new one that we only really
heard about with the poisoning of sergey
skripal
in salisbury a couple of years ago but
they all
work in exactly the same way it's
something that was developed in the
1980s we believe
by uh the russians um they were trying
to generate
a binary agent so they could get around
the rules
of uh the um the chemical warfare
prohibition rules that
had been set by the opcw and they signed
up to an international convention
um and it is the most deadly of the
different agents
but is absorbed primarily through the
skin
and that causes longer absorption times
and
a longer period of time for the effects
to take place
yeah and in terms of the the
administration of it
there was suggestion last month when
alexia navalny was first poisoned that
he may have been poisoned in
a cup of tea there has been more
speculation that perhaps
the uh novichok agent although that the
poison was
was placed in in items of his clothing
and then absorbed
uh through the skin from what we know so
far
alex navalny is the only person to have
been taken
ill like this whereas in salisbury we
saw a much wider spread
of contamination that that's the issue
at the moment is trying to identify what
the ground zero was and what the
methodology of
um him coming in contact with novichok
it's it's
a substance that has got very little
vapor pressure so
it could be sitting on the desk less
than a centimeter away from you
and provided you don't touch it you're
not going to get contaminated by it
and therefore it is very very specific
and you have to touch it
and it can be absorbed through the skin
or it can absorb
through protective clothing that you've
got um
a set of gloves or through other
clothing
and then comes in contact with the skin
and is absorbed into the body over a
period of time
causing increasing um uh symptoms
and we just don't know what the moment
alexi navalny will have come in contact
with this agent
sky news has been inside norfolk park
one of the country's worst hit hospitals
and the first to declare a critical
incident back in march
after running out of intensive care beds
our people in politics correspondent
nick martin
has met staff who have been doing their
best to prepare for a possible second
wave
this winter
northwick park hospital in london has
one of the highest
covered death rates in the country
the very first of thousands of cases
came through the door in the early
evening of the 4th of march this year
it felt like a one-off um and then
within two weeks we were seeing
20 to 30 a day and we doubled we were
doubling at a rate of about
every two to three days and within four
weeks we were seeing
80 to 100 cases a day very very sick
people came in very very quickly
franco paulo is a charge nurse at
northwick park
he developed coveted symptoms in
mid-april
i have fever and shortness of breathing
so we went to the hospital
my symptoms is getting worse
i was on the back seat of the of the car
my lips are getting blue
it's really trying to strangle you
at the hospital staff realize the
patient is actually a friend
and colleague i can see their worry in
their face
their sadness i can see some of them
crying also
and when franco doesn't respond to
treatment the decision is made to put
him on a ventilator
i told the consultant let me have a
quick word with my wife with grace
i told my wife i promised to her that
i'll come back
[Applause]
after five weeks in a coma franco beat
the virus
and pulled through i'm happy that
god gave me again a chance to wear again
the uniform
and to help out the people
metallica they have another side to them
i'm told and a new documentary
has been made about their work with the
san francisco symphony
it airs on sky arts on saturday at 9pm
do you want to have a listen
all right then
[Music]
we make you
drummer and co-founder of metallica is
joining us
now hello to you good to see you welcome
to the program
good morning good morning from san
francisco how
amazing i would not have immediately put
a band like metallica with the
san francisco symphony orchestra how did
that come about in the first place
well first of all thank you for having
me it actually came about in the first
place uh 20 years ago when we did this
in 1999 uh we were much younger then
the orchestra orchestra was skewing much
older and
a gentleman named michael cayman brought
the two of us together 20 years later
there is a new arena in san francisco
opening last year the chase center san
francisco finally gets a world-class
arena
and they ask if metallica will be the
first band the first event
actually to celebrate the the opening
and uh so we're thinking it's 20 years
since the
first go-around with the san francisco
symphony let's make this a celebration
for the city of san francisco before the
bay area for northern california so we
asked if they would collaborate with us
once again they said yes we did the
concerts we had a great weekend
the arena got opened everybody was very
happy
the cameras were rolling the tape
recorders were recording and now we
finally 11 months later have the album
out it was supposed to come out
three four months the album of the movie
was supposed to come out three four
months ago
but because of covid and the challenges
uh in the wake of that
uh but now it's finally here so i'm very
happy about that forgive me lars but i
mean
is it reasonable to say that your music
and the symphony
orchestra are potentially very different
types of music how does that meld
together
uh i think that's that's reasonable to
say uh
but metallic has always uh loved
challenges
and we have always been open to all
kinds of cool and crazy collaborations
so when michael came and brought this to
us
in about 97 96 97
we were totally game it took him about
two years
to write the arrangements orchestral
arrangements we finally did this
then for the first time in 99 we played
the couple shows in san francisco we
played in berlin
we played in new york it was a great
project
and we love metallica
loves being out of its comfort zone and
and stepping into
uh to know and unexpected challenges so
when this opportunity presented itself
again last year we were ready to jump
back in
how different is it this time to try to
get to the top of the charts
well when you've been around as long as
we have uh
we're we're closer to 40 years in 30
years
uh we'll take a number one obviously
it's not the reason we get out of bed
and it's not the reason we do these
projects but it's always much
appreciated and if
if anything it's about the fans and
about
the metallica family and how they make
this happen
uh obviously
uh in a surreal time the last six months
uh like i said before we were hoping to
get this record out in the spring
it's finally here i i would say for me
the most important thing is that the
fans are really
uh embracing this record the reception
has been
incredible i would say even better than
the first snm album
20 years ago so that's the most
important part but
i will definitely take it number one in
england
these things don't come around all that
[Music]
often
never never land
you